[Brett]: Oh, shit!
Sorry Wren.
[Nick]: Dude that's the first hambone right there.
[Wren]: DUDE! 1 DOLLAR!
[Brett]: 1 dollar?!
Dude I don't have a dollar.
I don't have a dollar today.
[Wren]: Not wearing a helmet, this guy..
[Ben]: Is everyone wearing new Christmas clothes?
*random noises of affirmation*
[Ben]: My new Christmas shirt, my new Christmas pants, my new Christmas shoes..
Why didn't you get any new Christmas clothes?
[Wren]: You can do that??
[Ben]: Yeah.
[Nick]: Did you guys all see Rogue One?
[Sam]: When you watch Rogue One, how do you feel?
[Wren]: Honestly, I was a little disappointed because everyone dies.
I was kind of hoping they'd do something a little bit more interesting than that.
I walked out of it going: "That was a very pretty film! Those VFX were awesome!"
[Sam]: And that's kind of where it ends because there's nothing that really sticks with you
[Niko]: You can't just be all negative Nancy's around here
How would you make a better Star Wars?
These big budget movies, they try to
to be perfect in every single way. They draw from a language of other
movies. What you get is this basically this giant big,
recycled version of a film that kind of touches upon all the tiny little things, things you've already seen and felt before.
It checks all your boxes for what a story needs, but it doesn't give you the same takeaway.
[Niko]: Here's the thing about Rogue One: main character Jyn, I can't name a single hard decision she makes in the entire film.
She's a main character that loses her agency. It's considered bad writing to have a character, a
main character, that is passive. What that means
is that the character sits there and everybody else tells that character what to do. Everybody else pushes that character through the plot. Everybody else
pushes that character through the story and the character says "Wooaah", along for the ride.
Versus a character having to make hard, active decisions.
Jyn didn't have a goal. She literally just sat there, and everybody else told her what to do. The best example of this is
at the very end when they're getting those hard drives.
Jyn
stands by the side, while freaking
Cassian or whatever his name is, is the man operating the hard drive machine.
Why isn't Jyn doing it? She was the main character.
[Sam]: This weak character, kind of, on a roller coaster throughout the whole thing,
that's a huuuuge
byproduct
of the fact that these movies are
constructed completely independent of the characters. When you plan these movies out to a tee where you know these
scenes are going to happen, blah blah blah, it's like the characters
don't even matter anymore, you're just writing the plot.
You're forcing these characters to just ride along with these decisions you've made.
It's not interesting.
[Niko]: You want to know why the part with Darth Vader, at the end, killing guys,
was so thrilling? It's not because you get to see Darth Vader kill guys. Seeing Darth Vader want something and
ACTIVELY go and try and take it, and suddenly all his power comes out like and you're like "Holy shit this guy's a huge badass. I didn't know
he was so scary. Cause the character's being active. He's going and he's making hard decisions. He's killing people to get his goals.
[Sam]: He has intentions, and he has obstacles. I love that thing. Thanks Aaron Sorkin.
[Niko]: Well what'd you think of Rogue One, Ben?
[Ben]: Every movie has to like feed into the next movie nowadays and all the characters have to be around for all the sequels and I
was just so happy that this movie
was like "*bleep* it. We're just-
everyone's dead. They didn't care and they weren't trying to just like set it up for a sequel.
They were just like "This is what we're gonna do."
[Niko]: Ben,
there's six more movies that came after this one.
[All]: *laughing*
[Sam]: What's terrible about it is that you kind
of go like... From the outset, the assumption is these characters aren't going to be that memorable because....
This is it. This is all you got them for so it's like
you don't get to build characters that are like "Damn, like, I'm gonna cosplay as
this one character.
[Niko]: That said, there's a couple things that Rogue One did correctly.
One: there were no Jedi in the movie.
Second thing that they did really well:
Acknowledging what most people said is a giant plot hole in Star Wars, which is "Why can you blow up a Death Star with the
simple Proton Torpedo in a exhaust shaft.
Making it a character-based crisis of conscience
is such a good way to approach that and is so compelling.
[Wren]: And this is also all just,
completely ignoring the fact that it is a very beautiful film. The effects are like some of the best out there on the market
right now. It's like, yeah, but that's come to be expected from,
you know,
ILM and Disney Films, it's like, it's
also just like
beautifully polished just like, alright.
[Niko]: In the trailer, there's a shot where
Jyn is running to I think it's like the little platforms to like recenter the
satellite dish, and a Tie Fighter rises up and cuts her off.
That shot was actually added by the trailer house. They were like "The shot's cool,
we need to jazz it up" and they added the Tie Fighter themselves. Probably with Element 3D.
[Niko and Wren]: *laughing*
[Niko]: So in a nutshell: if you want to make a better Star Wars movie, let your characters be active.
Don't make them passive. Don't worry about plot
holes, like studios are so concerned with people picking apart the movies on Reddit. That's fine,
they can do that. Just make a character
that has drive and emotion and ambition, and the audience will be along for the ride. I mean that's why
Luke Skywalker and Han Solo and Princess Leia are so compelling. Even in a sci-fi universe, all this crazy world building, make them character-based.
[YouTube video]: With Steven Bauer from *indecipherable*
and Richard Herd from "Planes, Trains and Automobiles"
in...
"Gleaming the Cube
[Brett]: Have you ever seen "Gleaming the Cube"?
[Ben]: Is that a skateboarding movie?
[Brett]: Yeah it's got, uh, Christian Slater in it.
And Tony Hawk.
Rodney Mullen.
I was three years old when this film came out.
[Jake]: Brett, what does "gleaming the cube" mean? It sounds perverted.
[Brett]: Uh no, basically it's a, it's a giant crystal cube. Gleaming it, basically like
you're taking 409 or a little bit, or, you're gleaming it.
Gleaming it.
[Jake]: You mean skate on it?
[Brett]: No you don't skate on it, you just gleam it.
[Jake]: What's the *indecipherable* have to do in the movie?
[Brett]: You gleam it. What's? What do you mean? Gleaming the cube. It's self-explanatory.
[Jake]: You don't even *bleep* skate on it? How is it a skateboard tournament if you don't even *bleep* skate on it?
[Brett]: You gleam the cube.
[YouTube video]: And he didn't care for the direction the world was heading.
[YouTube video]: "I don't know what's worse, you know? Blowing up in a nuclear war or having a 7-11-
[Wren]: Did you see that petition?
[Brett]: Yeah there was a petition.
[Ben]: I didn't really see it...
[Brett]: Ah actually, no. Is there... Is there still a petition?
[Wren]: There's a Change.org petition for Ben to shave his mustache.
[Brett]: So people hate Ben?
[Ben]: People hate winners is what it is.
[Brett]: Oh, wow.
[Ben]: Just kidding it's 2017, I don't, I don't feel that way.
*sarcastic laugh*